know what you're not even doing it right
it's like this side to side why are you
going in circles no its side to side
okay I've been doing that right hey guys
it's been a minute since I picked up the
camera a lot and nothing has happened
since the last time I picked up the
camera I have been sucked in to Animal
Crossing this freaking game is so
addicting so the past few weeks I have
been consumed by the game I would show
you my Island in case you guys were
curious and wanted to see it but it's a
hot mess right now because I just got
terraforming abilities and if you don't
play Animal Crossing you're like what
the heck does that mean
don't even bother looking into it do not
get the game because your life will be
gone he will have no life I actually
feel guilty about how addicted I am and
I was talking to KC about this but then
like I kinda like convinced myself to
make myself feel better because there's
so many elements about this game like
I'm exercising my brain a lot cuz like
there's a lot of math involved you learn
a lot about like economics
I feel like Ace Ventura pet detective
cuz I know about a whole bunch of bugs
and fishes and like how much they're
worth in the game or whatever and then
like fossils and like I'm learning about
dinosaurs and stuff I don't know man
this game is nuts
and then like Nikki and Jeana they're so
addicted to and so we just spend a lot
of our conversations talking about
Animal Crossing it's consumed our lives
for sure before I got addicted to this
game though I did manage to finish one
project and then start another and not
finish the other and these projects are
wallpaper projects cuz you guys know how
much I love my wallpaper around the
house look at this check it out
isn't she a beaut look at this I also I
hung up that shelf and got some towels
there to make it look fancy but yeah
look at how cool its wallpaper the
design accidentally matches the Beth
words that we
here and I say accidentally because I
never realized it matched until it came
in and I was like oh yeah it's like a
similar pattern what are the odds of
that so I'm really happy with the
bathroom and then every morning I stand
right here or actually I sit I spent on
the bathtub I sit right here and I brush
my teeth and then I just marvel at the
beautiful wallpaper I love it
I absolutely love it all these wallpaper
projects bring me so much joy everywhere
I walk around the house and I just see
like color and patterns and it just
makes me feel so happy and then the
other project the other want people
project which that one gave me a
headache
I have not finished it here it is so as
you can very clearly see this is not
lined up properly because when I started
this because you know how like the they
come in these kind of strips so I did
this strip first and then I moved on and
then it's like not exact it's it's okay
we got to ignore that and then I moved
around the window and then I got here
and I was like oh dang we have we have
like a lot of missing places and then
this whole strip here this was like the
last strip that I put and any really
smooth it very well so it actually
completely fell and it was all crumbled
up and I didn't even realize it but it
was like that for maybe like a day or
two because I completely walked away
from this project because it gave me a
headache and coming back to it like I
just hung it up really quick a few days
ago and it actually smoothed out pretty
well but I still have to align it better
to make sure that this is seamless oh
yeah this this wallpaper business is
some serious business because you have
to line up the pattern and it's a really
big headache in the bathroom I don't
really show you this but if you look
really really closely it's a little
crooked just walk over to it's made out
of vinyl so
like if you are trying to like align it
and stuff and then like it ends up
getting stretched so then it's a
headache and a half but I'm kind of
almost done with this and that's it
that's my last wallpaper project once
I'm done with this laundry room that's
it no more headaches and I can just
enjoy all the patterns and the color all
over this house
you guys know though what our cats doing
that we keep talking about and how he
has this issue with us where he keeps
pooping everywhere well he has been
pooping on the brand-new couch that we
got and so we figured he pooped on it
twice after the second time I'm like
this is not happening again now what
we're doing is we put all these cushions
on top of the couch and this blanket so
if he does poop it all least get on the
blanket because for some reason he will
not poop on any of these pillows so now
our cat has held us hostage to not have
a beautiful decorated living room
because this jerk will poop all over it
yeah I don't know we've been trying like
different things like for example in the
old house they had three litter boxes
and one of them they would almost never
use and like I guess the experts suggest
that you incorporate like one extra
kitty litter so if you have one cat you
should have two kitty litters yeah
two cats you should have three or four
kitty litters that third litter would
almost never get used so in this new
house we don't have a ton of space to
put kitty litters all over the place so
we took one away and so now we only have
two so one of them is in the laundry
room which I know you guys caught a
glimpse of a place in the laundry room
and then the second one is down here in
the downstairs bathroom and so this
bathroom it actually has a like a motion
sensor on the light switch so if we
leave a light on it'll automatically
turn off after some time and so we were
trying to experiment really what is
there with
cat no matter what helps we go - no
matter what we do we could have like the
cleanest kitty litter ever like nothing
in it like the pellets or change the pet
pee pads are changed like everything is
like pristine he'll still poop like on
the floor next to the kitty litter or
sometimes on our bed if we accidentally
leave the door open and no one's in the
room then he'll poop on the bed or like
he'll poop on the couch I was like no
listen find coop on the floor I'll put
up with that you can poop on our bed
that's messed up but I'll put up with
that but you will not poop on this
brand-new couch I refuse I freakin love
this couch so much so I'm like no like
we need to figure something out like
this has to stop like this has to stop
so what we did is we added a lamp in
here I guess this is kind of working
because he hasn't been pooping on the
couch but yeah right here's the kitty
litter because we read that some cats
don't like to poop like in enclosed
areas which that technically is not
enclosed but you know those like clothes
Kitty film what kind of kitty litters
and that some cats don't like to poop in
the dark for some reason they don't like
being in the duct so we're doing that
it's been working so far but I really
think what is working is the pillows on
the couch I don't know how to make this
more permanent because this is no way to
live guys we we can't even enjoy our
couch
it's freaking cat keep pooping on it so
I'm like dude I don't know what else to
do but we got that going on right now we
are thinking about moving the kitty
litter outside of the bathroom
altogether and squeezing it back here
maybe that might help because then he'll
be like with us or something I don't
know because another thing is that we
have to keep this door like slightly
open like this if it's more clothes like
this and the cats can get in but then we
need to leave it like open enough for
the little paw to get in and open it you
guys see our dining tables right here
this layout is kind of weird to have a
bathroom right there with the dining
table right here but because of the
close proximity I just want to keep that
door closed forever but we can't because
of the kitty litter quite a breath man I
could talk about pressing wallpapers and
house oh oops everywhere all day but
what do you have to read about the NBA
and about how they might take over
Disney World and come back after like 15
Orlando Disney World reportedly clear a
frontrunner for NBA's return venue
oh they might house all the NBA players
there one even Disneyland one where
there's a basketball court
like no fans like fanless and sandless
games is a weird weird world we're
living in weird world we're living in
it's kind of a tongue twister bet MMA
fight oh yes that was weird and a watch
yeah I was weird to watch so high here
oh this sounds like it hurts a lot more
now I know but then you read cuz I
didn't watch this part where you were
telling me how before the fight how they
do those like pre-fight interviews and
then they're just usually they're really
hype and like amped up or whatever then
this time they were like chill yeah like
one of the fighters is that you poking
fun at the fact there's no audience
member so they came under like trying to
like vegan in a new world we're actually
going on a field trip today because of
this view world that we're living in Jew
and B you know that macho shock that we
are investors in along with a lot of the
JK people so Jew and B has changed their
practices in how they do business now
because
the whole pandemic now it's really
important to have safety precautions
like extra extra higher like cleanliness
standards and all this stuff so we're
gonna go to the juubi shop which one
enroll is rolling yeah we're gonna go to
roll the next to this to everyone in
Westwood and wanna roll in height and
we're gonna check it out like see what
the actual changes are like to see it in
person because we do know what the
changes are but we actually haven't been
to store before the quarantined stuff
rice ball so they have stores that's
really I didn't get the rice balls the
rice balls are so freakin delicious I've
been craving at like crazy at your
favorite one I like the salmon one or
the spam and a one it's my favorite
minute hike I'm just gonna get the
flight I'll take all three yeah I like
all of them but you asked me my favorite
yeah URI prepared with your gym be
uniform yeah so I guess I made myself so
much of this morning and June me matcha
some high quality stuff this is all
ceremonial great and if you know
anything about matcha
it's that ceremonial grade is like the
highest grade of much I like the purest
like the best and then ocular like the
place that we get it from day have been
around for over a century and they just
they really take care of the the matcha
so we're really getting you guys some
high quality stuff and if you're
interested check out the link in the
description because there will be a link
there for you to buy your own matcha and
you can make them at home like I've
shown you guys before I think in the
vlog are in story I don't remember but
usually we have these risks called mug
mug bolting both up to bowl and then
like we get like one of these guys much
and then we use this guy to like to
whisk it up and be nice and foamy
because they actually sell this whole
kit - this is actually from back when I
used to be called sip before the rebrand
that's the one we have and I talked
about this before but I am such a fan of
the single pack serving one the matcha
sticks 10 in a box ticket anywhere we
want just put it in a water bottle shake
it up and you're good to go you get a
nice clean matcha energy
nice white teeth little coffee that
stains it yeah let's go get some actual
delicious much oh did you know that I
mean I know that you know Casey but did
you guys know that to me also has OVA
you can make boba at home you could
order it and then make it at home I'm
not a huge boba fan myself but the fact
that we're now offering that I was like
what that's so cool like I don't know
you can make boba at home usually people
the boba shops it's the new normal we
get to make both at home
I know we think we should we should make
be able to make rice balls that long - I
was about to say that you should come up
with a rice ball kit yeah is that how
you wear your mask I think we protected
yeah well we protect your eyes I need to
wear an hermes I don't want any
infections going through it your whole
completely safe on blind true we'll hold
your hand oh no but we can't see yet 6
feet away go away well anyway the suit
up
it says now open Chile Tom Cruise and
Top Gun he's always got his little thing
off to sign because they going to this
oh yeah he's like breathing hard I can't
do it right and he's like it look like a
ninja gangster you can't even see me
smile Oh
[Music]
salmon egg is one of my favorites all
right
here like the new safety measure in it
like caring for you starts with the
contact lens cleaning commitment control
check the temperature coverage contact
tracing so responsible I like it oh yeah
let's get really messy saying that
there's a distance between them and the
hole in the pixie glass all right
oh yeah I was there for that Josh I was
there for all these yeah that's in the
video that I made the six feet apart I
love it good job team all right yeah and
so very excited about the race love the
look were people coming in and we have
to be responsible and then walk out we
were trying to take photos I mean that's
the way of the world now you know we
gotta adapt it for help you've been out
together I think
yeah because Isaac and I went to a
grocery store one Casey and I have gone
to the grocery store as well
this is the first time we actually did a
family now what you get to do and be
this point because we're trying to take
photos and stuff to post on social media
then keep what we're trying to come in
so I was like oh we gotta go we gotta go
outside I think I do that it drinks oh
yeah okay now we can remove the mess I
like a breeze we can breathe I see you
gotta keep it clean that's what you put
on your face true no that's not how you
do it my boy
this is I mean I guess you can since the
lids are sealed now but but before this
is how they taught us yeah
yep know what your name is doing it
right it's like this side to side oh why
are you going in circles no it's side to
side okay I was doing it right but since
the lids are sealed you can just that
would be bad okay so look at this this
rosewater milk tea actually has rose
petals in it and it tastes so good
Yeah right where the oh you're something
have it cuz mine has a little hole
double doubts your excuses I love that
excuses get to stab your doubts and you
stack your fears
oh here you get to like punch punch it
basically that's tight that's what we
got to prepare daringly I think do you
know what John baby's June May it means
to prepare
yeah well daringly is added yeah the
word June be translated in multiple
Asian languages now that I've learned
from Bart David Jo Dan Mandarin it's all
similar in the fact that Joby means to
be to get ready to prepare that time
like we're empowering much with all that
Asian cultures together and it was like
a light bulb that went off in the river
was like what do languages seen the air
that's here which to your my language to
other exciting news for Jimmy we're
preparing to franchise and bring a Jun B
to a location near you my family has
decided open three Jewish shops in the
Dallas area if you're in Texas be sure
to be in Dallas and be sure to check out
that you'd be shot so I think there's
also like talks about other parts of the
country too so this is a really exciting
time for June B because of the fact that
we're now ready to franchise and this is
this whole franchising thing happened
obviously like way before the pandemic
happened so understandably you know you
might be thinking like why would anyone
want to open up a shop right now in the
middle of pandemic but interestingly
enough there have been so many
successful businesses that started
during like crisis times are like
recession times for example because in
the entire like business market not that
I know much about business but this is
actually like I was educated by a lot of
our partners that you know during
uncertain time
when the economy feels unstable it's
actually the best time for people to get
into a business it's kind of like the
whole bear market bull market thing
right where it's like when the markets
down it's a good time than five by yeah
when the markets up it's a bad time to
buy and then because then the stock only
goes up right I don't know if you guys
are interested or if you're like
franchising like opening up a business
that's so not me not about that you can
click on the link down below in the
description and let us know you can
actually vote for which city you're in
that you would love to see a June be in
because we want to know you know we
would love to know where people are
interested in having their own special
delicious doobie shop in your very own
City but if you are interested in
starting an entire business just like
Casey's family or technically they're my
family too just like just like my family
like you know oh yeah just like our
family how you know they've been very
very excited and so ready to open up
three of their very own shops so I'm
super excited to see how that process
goes because it's literally happening in
our very own family you guys are
interested also in franchising you could
check out the link in the description
there would be way more information I
don't know it just seems like a really
really exciting time because I genuinely
love this matcha and I just can't wait
for everyone in the world to like taste
it and really experience how to prepare
daringly oh I haven't even pictured my
doubts doubt the iron excuses
Isaac's doubting his drink oh you liked
it it's really good that's actually like
my number one most favorite a LaMotta my
number two favorite is the rosewater
matcha honestly this is the close close
number to close to number one I have a
close one two and three and I just got
my number one you've got my number two
and I got my number three I don't know
why I chose number three this is your
number three and those are your number
one cuz everytime we're here you always
order it well depending on when you ask
me and who and how I'm feeling
not one twos and threes change all the
time this could be another one any day
or I gotta taste it oh that's so good
you sure really taste the rosewater
infused in monster number one this
number one number two I think tasted
this is so good
Wow
if you ever want to just drink a spa
experience that's the drink to get and
you just feel like you're getting a
massage and a facial and you're
hydrating all at the same time I
actually wore this color shirts on
purpose because I knew I was gonna order
this drink not that it matters that all
makes it taste better it does I gotta
like being covered in pink with like
some some pink it just rosewater I want
to eat some rice balls right emotion
feminine you can have Isaac do you want
to you want those femininity salmon or
are you good family we're on our way
home we just visited juvy and we picked
up some Fryman as well and looking
forward to that but I think which was
asking us so I've been questions he was
asking us
what was pushing would you spend
unanimous responses basically saying do
you realize how much money a billion
dollars is I said you can clearly not
worth a single day for the rest of your
life like what would what would you do
and do you go week without eating food
but you have water and also equated
things like biologically that's right
for that long or like five days I think
he said and then it was like dude I
could do that now yeah you're literally
starve yourself hunger be like your
stomach hurts and like you're just like
ah man I'm hungry
I am fully comfortable with that feeling
so where I can live with that feeling
poor so then it turned over and to talk
about Disney landing whether or not we
could challenge ourselves to spend
entire year at Disneyland
with just our close friends that's a
pretty easy one oh one up you Isaac how
about this and you spend an entire year
at Universal Studios for Halloween or at
night billion dollars oh like if you
just glasses one year you'd be so rich
so rich it would be scary for like the
first
maybe wait two weeks then after that
maybe the best you'll just get
desensitized maybe that's what I would
be hoping for I'm on the big baby when
it comes to scary stuff you are you
never show feet yeah what happened be
the man sometimes and I try to show my
manly side but inside your front it's
not your friend
I think you feel scared oh sure yes but
if you're scared to adapt scared of like
oh because I'm gonna protect just me or
like a friend I get one friend yeah
Mikey Mikey doesn't seem like he's
afraid of anything
he's that type of dude that's right I
did yeah for a whole year
what if you were alone
Oh true maybe you know that's actually
how I get through the homes I think
those like scary is like you know you've
got through mazes or whatever dude the
way I get through them now is like I
don't let myself get sucked into the
world I mean I guess it's last month but
hey that's how I really call myself and
I just laugh every time I go through a
corner and someone tries to scare me and
just go and then it actually makes it so
much easier to get annoyed sadly that's
like the cheek day we all do when we're
on rollercoasters and the more you
scream at her on a roller coaster the
more you kind of like encounter the
scariness of the roller coaster the
g-force yeah yeah recently I was like
this last Halloween we did got to like
this haunted house thing with the girls
someone was really really really really
scared and I'm like girl don't worry I
got this
and then we're going through the whole
house and likely a lobster people are
like trying to scare us
oh because we have to grab certain items
out of each room so I can escape through
them as well well inside escape room
it's more like you collect all these
items and then you get something at the
end I forgot what it was I think was a
free drink or something
but like every room has like a scary
person dressed up and then you have to
like find this item so like something
for example one of the items were like
inside of a bathtub
like that's filled up with nasty-looking
water you have to have to stick your
hand in the bathtub to retrieve that
item of that room and so I was alone
getting all the items I'm like oh is it
here is it like right here are you sure
are we gonna do this thing or whatever
like I was just talking to them link I
don't know like they're just normal
people and then I've never go
what about like oh you what got me there
I like the point but that's I mean if
you're really scared of those like
Haunted Mansion
laugh it off and it feels like i legit
was scared most of the time but because
i was just laughing it off like a baby -
just that much more fun
it looks so beautiful on this online and
it's like golden hour I think that's
like the first time I'm getting sweaty
every time people really took the
shelter ending to heart just been
consumed with and
like literally this whole time that
we've been out here let's get home so I
can play just get home like bricks up my
high limp is it's a mess right now what
star are you at two stars no I already
got a four star four star Island at a
5.0 hey that's pretty good
Shh I gotta get it up to his life so I
can get that gold and watering can
[Music]